and we got we got a lot to talk about
but uh elijah we got to talk about the
riots man
oh we we have a lot to talk about people
have seen the clips
but they don't get a lot of the context
you are
on the ground yeah i unfortunately my
life's been on the ground
for 27 years i mean no i've been
i've been on the ground watching things
that i never thought i would see with my
eyes like face to face you were just in
kenosha
i was in kenosha for longer than i
thought and you know what's weird about
that
kenosha people don't realize kenosha's a
little bit north of chicago
yep i was actually in chicago covering
black lives matter unrest
when the riots broke out in kenosha
interest and i had to get a rental car
and go drive up to kenosha
how long did it take you to get there
like a half hour 45 minutes 90 minutes
90 really it took me 90 minutes i don't
i don't i don't know why maybe it was
traffic
maybe that was traffic yeah i mean it
was it was it was pretty it was it was
there's toll roads and just weird stuff
so were you on the south side of chicago
without with the riots or was it like
that um
well specifically i was in i was in
downtown um i was staying at the hotel
chicago
which is not that glamorous but it's all
right it's like a three-star hotel it's
what you get in the media business
it's like it's like kind of
gross-looking isn't it like on the
inside
you know chicago always feels like
somebody's going to come out with like a
tommy gun and
and light you up the hallways are always
oh no no no no
no they come out with it with like a
glock
sideways well it feels it feels like you
have 1930s 1940s organized crime
you know decor and feel but with like a
modern like
uh you know south side gang kill you
with a glock kind of
yeah it's interesting because you used
to have the chicago accent and it's kind
of gone away now
so where it used to be a you know walk
scene
you know they pull up their gun now it's
just a regular guy like how do you do
sir
this is my gun bang and you're like oh
i'm dead well chicago chicago what
people don't realize too is is
uh there was a free r kelly um protest
going on there which apparently has a
whole cult
in chicago that follow him like a god
but in order to
to calm the riots and the looting you're
talking about on every city block in
chicago right now or at least
last weekend that i was there between
seven to ten squad cars per block with
about 20 to 30 officers posted
like a post apocalyptic just heavy
police presence like
are they hiring people out of you know
out of like their house and i don't know
where they got all these cops from i
really didn't even know so this was
because of the looting in chicago yeah
because
lori lightfoot and the and the
commissioner decided that
obviously they were getting bad pr
there's only a certain amount of looting
and writing that you can allow in your
city
there's a funny thing it should be zero
but all right i mean i mean
well i counted at least three buildings
completely destroyed
just next to my hotel um really really
sad
stuff it really i mean when you look at
it if you live in a big city you know
exactly
the scene i'm talking about
unfortunately it's it's more cities than
just chicago
but what it was was a complete
occupation
a police occupation so if you want to
talk about less police
actually by allowing the rioting you're
causing an increased police presence if
you just stopped it in the beginning
then you wouldn't have all these police
out but it i have never seen i'm telling
you to him lydia i've never seen
that many police in maybe a 12 city
block area
it was basically the whole at least at
least half of the department would have
just been there
all day and that's not going to stop if
the riots go to the neighborhoods
chicago is huge
and they did black lives matter went to
whit and said they went to whitney high
school in chicago and they marched the
neighborhoods yelling
and i'm not making this a race issue
they were pointing out hey look at those
white people up there
yeah look at okay you come down here you
join us and they started blasting rap
music which
which is sounded pretty lit actually is
pretty good you know pretty good sound
system they had
the mobile sound system they started
blasting it to wake up the neighbors get
them out
screaming at them pointing left and
right you white folks get down here and
there was a real racial tension
in the suburbs and i've seen this in
in seattle in portland i mean we're
seeing this
across the country that that even as we
increase security in the cities
they are coming to our houses and i'm
not fear-mongering i've been saying it
man
it's earlier in the year or even last
year i mean
three years ago i was like man it looks
like civil war
and a bunch of people were saying things
like i'll calm down everything's fine
and it wasn't like me just making things
up i i i referenced this all the time
was it was an article in the atlantic
saying you know tensions are escalating
possibly civil war's becoming real
and then a lot of these predictions that
i made they were not grandiose
predictions but they started coming true
like i was like oh man i think we're
going to start seeing major riots based
on what we saw with trayvon martin and
michael brown
this is going to keep happening then
eric garner and then people are like oh
calm down there's not going to be
you know racialized protest and then
boom there there it goes and then riots
and then it gets worse and worse and
worse
because the media fans the flames but
i'll tell you this
part part of what you know leads me to
where i am speaking
in terms of you know not wisconsin and
stuff i was in wisconsin in
i think it was 2016
i think of where there were there was
rioting
because this dude got shot and killed it
was a black dude
and when i was there there were a bunch
of people
yelling things like get the white people
and an 18 year old white kid got shot in
the neck with a 22.
he wasn't even part of the protest he
wasn't anywhere near it this was in
milwaukee
he was just like crossing the street and
someone saw him and shot him and he took
a bullet in the neck
fortunately he was a 22 but it did hit
his spine
and so but so again look this is not
i think the good people in this country
know
it's not about race but there are
certainly racists in this country who
want to be
the the kid himself was saved by a black
dude you know who who rescued him and
then the cops came in and and
brought him away in an uh an apc but it
was
there were a lot of racist people and
they were
directly targeting people based on race
and so i made a video where i said
straight up
it is dangerous to be here if you are at
least perceived to be white or
perceivably white so
i i can't cover this anymore and i made
a video about it and boy did i get
you know crapped all over from so many
lefties like you're racist
i'm like a key got shot in the neck bro
and they were yelling like get him
get the white people and so i was just
like having grown up in chicago and
and seeing look racism exists across the
spectrum
it doesn't matter what your race is you
can be racist the life tries to deny
this
i was like i can't you know i can't be
out here you know a lot of
a lot of people felt the same what felt
similarly and i was actually i've been
told this by
far left activists that white people
shouldn't report
in you know for poc events i you know
what i i'm gonna share my experience hi
my name's elijah i'm a person of
colorlessness
um i'll let you know i have a theory
we're all people of color
i think it's such a stupid phrase
honestly people of color i mean i found
out what people of color was in in
college because
this was during like the rise of the
social justice warrior um
you know back in in the early 2010s
and i remember that i had used the
phrase um
the the opposite phrase which was to be
colored people and my professor gave me
a c minus and told me that was a
pejorative
um that was that was considered
discriminatory
now it's it's not on on the adl level
but i i didn't know that i actually
didn't know i didn't know that i'll be
honest when they say that you're
ignorant or not woke
i i honestly i just had heard that and
to be fair i just spoke to some liberal
people who used the same
phrase recently and i didn't know they
didn't know that that had changed
and she told me it was a person of color
that was the first time i heard of it
well
that's fine okay cool i'll use that it's
been offensive for a long time
i just didn't know it though right the
the latest thing is that you have to say
a person of disability
or like you know so you don't say a
disabled person so you don't put you
don't put the descriptor before because
i mean this is where i'm a bit
uneducated here
and so the social justice narrative is
that they're people first okay so
not so that's where people of color
verse and and
people of disabilities and people of
whatever else but but see this is where
it gets weird to me because
because when you get down into it you
know this i said fine okay like
i'm okay with that okay i just didn't
know that i'm going fine i'm in college
i apologize whatever
i got a c minus or whatever on the paper
for an ignorant mistake according to her
and i'm just a you know young kid and i
didn't realize it what class was this
uh this was this is upper division
theology like you're getting marked down
on your grade because
this was the same theology class at
azusa pacific university where she said
she made us imagine what if jesus was uh
homosexual because of
the leaning of the chest at the at the
last supper and even though not
realizing that was an artwork it was
basically everything that's wrong with
christianity and theology
in the modern era and post-modern
anti-theology class it was like one of
those theology class that is probably
run by an atheist feminist
that knows nothing about a personal
relationship with jesus christ
and claims to uh be a herald and a
sponsor it was it was it was like
seminary
um and i remember like i was there and i
remember thinking that was weird because
i
actually my degree is in molecular
biology that's my my my
focus and genetic engineering and stuff
i remember thinking person of color
that's that goes against all confines of
science we are all people of color
like everybody is everybody but i'm
sitting on a scientific
term with
that's where i first started realizing
that politics doesn't follow
logic it doesn't follow science yeah it
doesn't follow
any sort of basis for reason because
i'm going look i'm freckled i'm a person
of concentrated color
like you know i've got i'm i'm i'm a
lobster like if you look at me on the
camera
i'm basically a hue of red or pink
like i mean i mean and it's just so
weird when i go to these events i don't
think about race i don't think about all
these things until i go to these events
is what i'm trying to say
and i'm around these people that are you
know fighting me saying you were racist
or fighting
the white people up there and who's
talking about race who's talking about
division
who's sowing the seeds of discourse and
problems in our country
it's those who are heralding unification
well
they claim to be heralding unification
they're not they're heralding division
like digitization or balkanization they
want to separate everybody
that's that's one of my biggest problems
with everything that that's been going
on
so when you see you know like these
these riots
which are seeking to enforce through
terror this ideology
then for me it's it's the same issue
right
that's why recently i came out today i
was gonna vote for trump specifically
for this reason
you've got look there's only there's
only so look
early on when you see like the sjws and
culture and gaming and all that stuff
it's like wow we better do something
about this
now it's in government now the cdc 10 of
their employees
wrote a letter demanding that the cdc
declare a national health crisis
of racism and i'm like is that real yes
yeah i mean i believe you i just wish i
wish you were lying
it makes no sense but we've seen cities
across the country do it
declare racism to be a public health
crisis and then what do you do
what are you supposed to do with that
like oh
because it's true were you discriminated
against people now like i don't know
what you're trying to tell me by saying
that's the case
it seems like it doesn't actually make
any sense
it's just meant to be a play for power
right i you know and this is where
i want to bring things up because on one
hand i want to be really fair
and i think that there's a weird faction
of the right wing that that goes
we're all equal everybody's got an equal
playing field yeah yeah yeah
but also too like that kid in the
wheelchair probably won't be as good at
football as
that six foot five 280 pound freshman
just just i'm not i mean i'm not
predicting i'm just going to say
there are some things that either we're
born with or even our families or
socioeconomic status
that in the less terms do allow us and
make us privileged in their this is
their words not mine
into having maybe certain opportunities
do i agree that america is the best
place to overcome the disparaging
differences and and negativities in your
own life yes
but i i think that if we're gonna have a
conversation about
you know problems economically or
culturally in the black community
or issues with race relations between
white and black people and why that
exists based on certain crime stats or
issues
i'm okay with that i think those
conversations should happen especially
in areas of academia
but when you take the intellectually
lazy
response or approach and just say well
it's that inherently all white people
have internalized misogynist misogyny
imperialism and racism that's just
racism right but i'm saying like and we
and we and we all are somehow against
black people black people therefore
cannot be racist because
racism is really discrimination with
power this whole you know this whole
critical race theory it's just bs the
the issue is that
the left is overtly racist they're
avowed racists
and i'm not making this up no i agree
the uh robin d'angelo
what is that her name yeah robin she's
been a vowed racist
d'angelo sponsored by corporations
avowed
let me show you some proof check this
out i got this tweet here from rod dr
rodriguez he says northwestern
university law school had a town hall
meeting
online recently everybody began with a
ritual denunciation of themselves as
racist
the reader professor sveta is not racist
he is a wonderful man universally loved
by students
it makes me sad that he is forced to say
otherwise i don't i don't i don't care
whether he was forced to say it or not
because i don't know what you're talking
about i know who the guy is
all i can tell you is this here's a text
message where emily mullin i don't know
she is says
she's a racist sarah summervoid says she
is
a racist and james betta says he is a
racist they are a vowed
racist stop listening to their opinions
i'll tell you this
when when you see the black lives matter
sign pop up on netflix or
i want you to go to the people who run
the boston red sox and say
so this person here's a chapter in their
book where they say they're a racist is
it normal policy for you to
build your marketing based off of overt
racism why do you hate minorities
they straight up say right here they are
racist
they're saying it to us why are why is
anyone on the left listening to them
listen this is where my mind
fireworks just my brain explodes because
what i've always noticed too is it's the
people lecturing us that are the ones
going hey look man let me let's it's
like this being like look man
i want to talk to you about your violent
tendencies and fixing them i'm a
murderer
i i've ripped people's heads off with my
bare hands and i want to talk to you
about how you're violent you go
wait wait a second i'm not violent and
they go have you ever been mad at
someone and you go yeah and they go
have you ever had a secret thought that
you wanted to take someone's life
even even faintly and you go not really
and they go well have you ever just like
watched a movie and wondered how it's
done you go yeah you go see there you go
you're a murderer and you go well hold
on
no i i literally no wait wait hold on
so i look i'm i'm not going to read
actually that
that's that's an ignorant thing to say i
should definitely read white fragility
my my understanding of it and to be
completely fair is based off of
critical analysis from some people make
a show out of it and just do it with
your audience they would like
to watch it i'd imagine that the video
would get taken down for the things she
says
do you know that so so correct me if i'm
wrong but she says that
she is uncomfortable around black people
robin d'angelo or whatever
she says that when she walks into a room
full of black people she feels
uncomfortable
and that's i again my understanding is
coming from critical analysis from other
people but if that's true
i mean she's an avowed racist i don't i
don't understand that that feeling
you know i grew up in an area with all
these different people different races i
don't feel uncomfortable around people
but they know they're racist see you you
come up with a good point and
i can't out these people because now
they have really high high
ranking level jobs and big corporations
and there
may or may not have relation to me so i
have to be careful here
but you know i've watched them they're
they're staunch liberals staunch
democrats on the left
they're not liberals well i'm just
saying like according to their own
they're self-about self-described
and the things they say about uh
minorities in the united states are
things
i've never thought to even say and i'm
going no wonder why you think everyone's
racist because you have such racist
thoughts about people
that you think we all do like like like
i then
for instance i was in an elevator with
one of these people and these asian
people walked in
and this is their words not mine do not
take me out of context and i'm going to
use this don't quote
me i'm going to yeah translation
of like oh my gosh like why they said
why are asians
so like not aware of their social
surroundings and so annoying and i
literally sat down and
they're standing right there like how
would you just say that out loud now
this person fights racism they're
against racism everything i'm going
well no wonder why you're fighting
racism whenever like an asian just maybe
coincidentally like just
maybe is in a conversation ignores you
and you assume that all asians are just
ignorant of
social spaces in public that's a
discriminatory thought across the board
because not all asians are first
generation so
you know going back to the point you
made where you're like the murderer says
i've ripped you know people's heads off
see the counterpoint i would have is if
robin d'angelo came to me
and she told me she was an avowed racist
who is uncomfortable around you know p
brown people or black people whatever
and then she said have you ever had this
thought i'd say
no i i can i can honestly say that's not
the case
maybe it's because i come from a you
know uh mixed race family
no i don't you mixed race family what's
your what's your transition korean
you're part korean yeah that's what i
said might tell you you're so smart
you know what's really funny about this
though uh i was talking to a friend of
mine
and we were talking about youtube
demonetization and like shutting down
channels
and i was like you know they were saying
it's political and they're targeting the
right and i said
i think it's kind of everybody like my
mom makes math tutorial videos and they
came and demonetized her
and then my friend was like why am i not
surprised your korean mom makes math
videos
and the first thing i did was i texted
my mom i was like this is amazing and my
mom was laughing about it she loved it
she was funny
because we know it was it was supposed
to be mocking the stereotype you know
what i mean it's supposed to be
it's good humor no no the idea when when
this person made this joke was not to
insult me
it was to actually like insult the
stereotype
it was like there's this silly
stereotype and there here's a joke and
we laugh about it
like like like what i don't under you
know how i know that it's all bs
because if we can still laugh at racist
jokes towards white people
then people still understand that
there's a difference between humor and
culture
and real actual hatred in your heart
like if you can still make a joke about
a white person and be like
you know like let's say i try to like
dunk a ball and i miss or something and
someone goes yeah nice jump white boy
and i'm not like i've had a black guy
say that to me on a basketball court
believe it or not
i play basketball sometimes bad at it
because i'm left-handed and
i've compound fractured my left arm so
the ball always goes a little bit
some weird direction just turn your body
slightly yeah it's very
very very odd like the world uh right
now just in weird direction but i but i
will say this that
you know when someone says oh you can't
jump i don't think like oh there's a
black guy that hates white people i'm
thinking
he's just mocking it like there's tons
of white people who jump in
in the nba nobody thinks white people
inherently can't jump but there's just
stereotypes like white people like bland
food white people
don't dance yeah yeah but like nobody's
like if i dance it's funky and someone
says oh you can't dance because you're
white
i'm not offended but hold on there's
actually there actually is a good
counterpoint to this
i see a lot of these lefties say things
like white people have no culture
which is derivative of this you've heard
this before though right
yeah i think it's stupid like didn't
trudeau say something in canada about
like canadians have no culture or
something
are you do you remember that i don't
remember that right often
what is true who even wants to remember
what trudeau says seriously good point
that's a good point it's a good one
but so deriving from these jokes people
take them seriously and i think this is
a perfect example of why you get people
on the left who feel the way they do
they literally are racist they are
telling us they are screaming in our
faces
and people look man with all due respect
this guy uh
rod who says reader you know spada is
not a racist um it's it's i said he has
to say this i'm like no no no anybody
who says they're a racist i'm gonna
believe him
you like listen if if if you're that
spineless where you're like
you know you know the star trek thing
there are four lights
no captain enlightenment captain picard
gets kidnapped by
it's an alien race okay do not call the
cardassians
and they're torch yeah for real yeah
they're really gross looking so don't
do they have do they have artificial
butts no they don't it was well before
the
the kardashians but anyway they they
they're torturing him
and he said there's four lights in front
of him and he's like there are five
lights and picard keeps saying there are
four lights and like defying that they
were trying to force him
to believe this it's very it's very
similar to what we've been seeing lately
with the two plus two equals five thing
you've seen that
yeah so you have these people right now
if they're saying they're racists
i'll take their word for it i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna argue games i'm not
gonna say oh they must have been forced
to admit
publicly that they were racist like dude
if you want to come out and say you're a
racist i'll take your word for it
i don't have anything to do with you and
i don't think we should be listening to
your opinions if you would say that
thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you